Wyoming has just become the first state
to Outlaw abortion pills a Wyoming
Governor Mark Gordon has signed a bill
on Friday outlawing the abortion pills
it's called the prohibiting chemical
abortions Bill and it says that anyone
who prescribes distributes or otherwise
provides abortion pills can face a
prison sentence of six months and a fine
of nine thousand dollars awesome love it
I want to see every other Republican in
the country pushing this stuff this is
where the pro-life movement is moving we
overruled Roe v Wade took 49 years we
did it that's great that's not the end
that's only the beginning we've got to
keep pushing the left never stops
pushing the left pushes the sexual
Revolution all the way from feminism all
the way down to chopping off your kids
genitals all right they never stop they
just keep moving moving moving we got to
keep moving moving moving too